so hi my name is Anton and I want to
talk about small data
I feel bit odd because everybody talked
about big data and machine learning and
here I come in the same oh look at small
binary files okay so but about me I work
at a company called transit app oh it's
a bit distorted I'm sorry for that I
hope it's still really so transit AB is
well it's a transit app it's really
distorted it looks prettier if it's not
so distorted and basically what the app
does is you open it up and it tells you
what's nearby in terms of transit it
basically says when does the next train
go or the next bus all of these things
so it's like a way to get around and if
you open up the app that's basically
what you see and one thing that I work
on is making sure that when des shows up
it's really really fast like you
basically open it up it's pretty much
immediate and the way we do this is with
our approach to data so usually when you
design an app like that that shows
something like a schedule you would have
the app just as a thin client to some
servers on the web so basically the app
comes in and says okay the user asked me
to show something so can you tell me
what's nearby so then the server comes
back and says well here's a bunch of
schedules here's what's gonna depart
soon so then the app says oh thank you
and it shows it to the user and our
approach was to have the server send a
full set of schedules to the app and
then the app can say what I need to know
is show something to the user well now I
actually have the complete set of
schedules I don't have to go ask the
server I can just answer this question
myself right now so if you open up the
app right now in Berlin it will download
the complete schedules on the first load
that's the complete schedules for Berlin
and London book of everything so that
sounds kinda crazy but it works so the
advantage of this is it gives us a
better user experience for one if you
open up the app or you move around on
the map it basically can answer the
question what's there immediately
because rather than going to a server
which may take some time you might be on
a bad connection or whatever
you just have to open up a file you have
to look into the file and get the data
out of that but it also means that it
works offline which you know it's an app
that is for users to take the subway
sometimes on the ground you don't have a
connection so sometimes it's actually
pretty convenient also it's for people
who travel so if you go to another city
you don't have a data connection you can
still use the app so that's kind of neat
as well but also it means for us for our
infrastructure that our server doesn't
have to answer every single request from
the app there's basically no load on our
servers because only when when the user
when the app hasn't done all of the data
yet and does the does the app make a
request to our servers and say ok what's
what's nearby it has to do this because
you can't just assume that you can
always have the data available and
downloaded but overall we can have like
millions of requests served from our
server because our server doesn't serve
most of these requests they're served
within the app so the problem with
sending whole schedules to advice is
that the schedules are actually pretty
big so I took a quick look to schedule
for Berlin that's the DVB schedule I
don't know whether that means anything
to you that's basically the transit
Association covering all of Berlin in
Bundaberg it's about 26 megabyte file
for Montreal just the the metro and the
buses is about 44 megabytes so that's a
lot of data if you're on a connection
that's like 3G that's like 200 kilobits
that's like a slower 3G connection if
you would download that file at the
bottom it would it might take like half
an hour that's way too long so we have a
special binary format that is also
includes a bunch of compression where
these files get much much much smaller
so for the Berlin data it compresses
down to about 2 megabytes it's about a
tenth for the SCM data it compresses
even further to about half a megabyte
that's about a hundredth so now we have
a bunch of data that's basically the
size of a large image file or website or
something like that so now we can you
can download this data without even
asking permission to the user you don't
have anything that says would you like
to download the schedules now it just
does it you don't even notice it you
don't even know it I think most users of
our app don't even realize that the
schedules are available offline so
in order to do this to understand how
this is done well maybe I should mention
how transit data is usually stored so
trend the data which you know it's like
a detour to something that maybe it's a
bit strange to some people but anyway
transit data is stored and usually in a
format called GTFS it's a format that a
google came up with together with the
transit agency called TriMet it's
basically a zip file that contains a
bunch of CSV files and these CSV files
act like a database it's like a dump of
their database but this format has
evolved as being the standard and it's
used all over the world and we get this
data for you know several hundred
agencies all over the world in this
format so if you look at it the Berlin
feed which I just named vvv zip right
now inside it you'll have this bunch of
CSV files that I actually built as text
files so since it's a zip file if you
uncompress all of these text files
they're actually 250 megabytes big so
already the data is compressed right at
26 megabytes and you have text files one
is called stop times which is basically
just for every trip in the schedule it
says for every stop that the trip passes
by what time does it pass by at that
particular stop so that's basically all
of the numbers that are in the schedule
then there's a list of all the trips a
list of all the stops a list of all of
the routes and it has all the data
associated that you need with it so the
way I looked at the data is to say well
the stop times the extra schedules
dislike a bunch of numbers that's like
numerical data and all of the other data
that basically tells us what is the
structure of the network what are the
routes where do they stop what you know
where are the stops and all of the stuff
I sort of consider that more like
structured data if you store it you know
it would be like a giant tree or
something like that and or like a
database where things refer to each
other all the time so if you want to
make this data are smaller naturally
because the stop times are so large one
would look at the stop times first so if
you look at the actual stop times file
it's basically you know a database
looking thing a huge text file that is
incredibly verbose
where every row is basically one
particular data entry one particular
time like an arrival and the departure
time at a particular stop for a
particular trip and you also see the
stop sequence numbers for so for every
stop that the trip makes it goes and has
one of these entries it's like that's
not how I would think about a schedule
but that's what they do because it's
basically a dump of the transit database
the way I would look at a trip is more
like this this is actually I just don't
notice yesterday for the M tantrum which
passes by here at some point so this is
also a schedule and this is much more
compact so here you see every row is
basically a stop and every column is
basically a trip so you can basically go
to a stop and then read off the times
when the particular term you know when
the trams pass by and then if you change
the data format the layout from the
previous very verbose one to this more
smart representation that uses a matrix
you you already gain a lot of space so
already if you take this data to stop
text file it's like two and a mega it's
big and you store these matrices and
then you only use as many bits as you
would need to store minutes and then you
pack them all together in binary you
it's like 10 megabytes big that's like
still too big but I mean it gives you
some idea that that really you can get a
lot better and then we have our own
compression we actually spend some time
and set ourself okay
well let's come up with some compression
that makes this better and we wanted to
have compression where you don't
actually have to decompress all of the
data because if you have to decompress
all of the data then on the device
suddenly you have to store like 10
megabytes of data on the device for
every feed so that's too much so we have
a special compression that allows you to
look into the data without actually
decompressing the whole thing is like
completely random access and it's like
very domain-specific and I don't really
want to go into it too much except to
say that one way to think about that
it's obvious that you could compress
data transit data a lot is because the
data is very regular like if you look at
this matrix then you basically set it
between every column the data is like
monotonically increasing right it's 21
24 and
it was ten minutes later and then
between every column in between every
row it also is monotonically increasing
like between every stop to the next stop
is always like one or two minutes and
often these differences are the same
across a row or a column so there's a
lot of regularity not a whole lot of
entropy so that's where our compression
comes in and that gets it down to you
know 5% of of the size of the schedules
so now we have compressed our numerical
data but now we have a bunch of
structured data so basically if you have
an app or something like this and you
say okay let's push some data on to the
user you'll probably also have not this
weird you know scheduled data which is
very domain-specific but you have a
bunch of structured data a bunch of tree
data like a database or something like
this and what are you going to do with
that at this point this data is actually
much larger than the scheduled data so
we have to find a way to present it in a
compact way if we want to send the data
to the to the user at all times so how
can we store the structured data well oh
in order to make this discussion easier
I just want to talk about stops and not
all of these other structures to be able
to show this some stuff so one way to
store a bunch of structured data is to
use Jason I mean it's pretty simple
everybody uses it that's also what the
web service would use if you've made a
you know web-based app and you could say
you know that in if you wanted to
compress well it's not actually
compressed if you just wanted to store
the data then all you would have to do
is basically turn take out the data that
you want to store put it inside objects
and then use the JSON module and Python
to store it note here actually that my
compressor for the for the schedules is
actually written in Python
so that's sort of what it would look
like if I was would use JSON I would get
an array of stops take out the values I
need and then turn it into Jason right
now I've the values I got is like the
name of the stop its location allowed to
do longitude the code is like is a
number that defines to stop you know
within some you know for example for the
real-time thing to say okay you know for
the real-time API to so that it knows
what stop is referring to there's some
boolean value that knows whether it's a
station and the service pattern I
is like some magical number that we come
up with internally because we need to
know what service is actually stopped at
a stop like what routes what what
schedules and all of this stuff so that
we have some one magical number that
does that so one with Jason is it's
actually pretty big so for the stops
it's like two megabytes and sure it
would compress a little but there's just
a lot of like stuff in there that keeps
repeating and it's sort of annoying so
Jason is great because you know it's
easy to use it is human readable so you
get it's easy to debug it's
self-contained meaning that if you look
at a JSON file you can figure out what
these values mean you don't need to have
a separate guide that says well this is
the name of a stop because you see that
the structure is defined so that's very
convenient the bad thing is that the
files are pretty big and then if you
want to load the data you also have to
parse the data so if you want to load
megabytes of Jason say you know you took
put Jason and then you compress the
Jason because you need it smaller so you
have to decompress it then you have to
parse it you have to store it in memory
in some way we're just gonna use up a
lot of memory and then it's all just
gonna be very slow so one way to maybe
turn into binary but still keep what
Jason does is to use something called
message pack and message pack defines
it's like they advertise themselves as
saying they're like Jason but fast and
small and message pack is almost like a
drop-in replacement for Jason so you can
actually just tell a message back well
here's a Jason just you know turn this
into binary and it will so here I have
the code which is basically the same as
I had before the only difference is
rather than packing it and Jason and
turning into a string I just turn it
into a message pack thing so then well
previously the Jason looked sort of like
this the message pack will actually
create a bunch of you know binary
gobbledygook but if you look at the at
the data you notice that inside the data
you actually store all of the keys
there's name latitude longitude write
the name there's the name of the streets
the latitude and a bunch of binary data
that's probably
latitude and longitude so you basically
keep storing all of these keys like we
have all of this data and they're most
like what we wanted to save space if you
want to save space we don't want to
store the name and the latitude and
longitude those words because we kind of
know what those things are we know that
there's a name stored and we know that
there's a lot of cute stored so in
message back you can actually use a
custom encoding a custom serialization
and the way you would do that is you
would basically just go through all of
the values that you're interested in it
and just drop them into a buffer you
would just tell that message back okay
well this is a string here this call
it's the name and then add that to the
end of the stream and then you say oh
well there's a lot you add that to the
end of the stream and it turns it into
some binary thing and then it just puts
it in there
and then when you want to read out the
data you can do it again you would
basically say okay well now the stops
are coming so how many stops are coming
right so I actually wrote the length the
number of stops so that if you read them
out you say okay I'm reading out this
many stops and then you really stop you
just read them out in a verse right you
say okay well first is the name then a
latitude and a longitude then the code
then the question whether the station or
not and then the service pattern ID
value and then it's next time so this
way you basically have the same as
before except now we don't store a bunch
of keys that data is gone right so so
now basically the the tool that that
compresses the data and the tool that
reads the data they have to agree on a
format right they have to be written in
tandem because otherwise you're not
going to be able to get your data back
the way you wanted it so now the data
looks sort of like this again a bunch of
binary gobbledygook you see the name of
the stops and there but you don't see
any of the keys so in order to
understand how this message pack
actually works it's actually it's
actually relatively simple and clever
format what what they do is when they
pack a particular datum or a particular
value they use the first Bay by it to
identify what is the type of this and
then for example if you look at the
values I turned all of the things that
are not strings into hex values the the
first byte is a b6 which actually
signals to message
that well this is a string that has the
fixed length 22 so then the next 22
characters are the string and then the
next thing is the next number which is
the next value which is a float which is
defined by the CP values so the CP value
says the next eight bytes make up a
64-bit floating-point value and then
again there's another 64-bit
floating-point value the value 0 well
just refers to the integer 0 the value C
- that's a boolean false and then again
there's another 0 so this first byte
some of the values are just saying what
the value is like - or false
some of them saying well there's an
array coming up of values you have to
figure out what those values are some of
them are saying this is a string and if
the string is short it encodes inside
the bite itself the length of the string
and then also for integers you can store
numbers up to like under 28 and that by
it actually knows well that's 100 you
know that's that particular number let's
say 64 it only uses one single byte so
it's a very compact representation and
it's actually relatively simple so
message back is great because it's easy
to use and it's self-contained in the
sense that if you look at a particular
byte in the stream you kind of know what
type it has but you don't know what
semantically it is I don't know that
okay I know it's a string but you have
to know elsewhere that its name you have
to have agreed beforehand that there's
going to be the name of a stop or the
latitude or the longitude the
representation is very compact and
overall it's great for small messages
but if you consider that you might have
megabytes of data and you want to load
the you want to load it inside a mobile
application and you load it and then you
have to parse it and then you have to
store it inside some sort of memory
representation because you know universe
need to parse it then stored in the
memory in order to be able to access the
data that may still take a fair amount
of time so once your daughter gets too
large it may not be so great so it's not
really the best for sort of large
structured data it's very great for like
small messages that you send to people
oh and by the way we went from the Jason
before right so the Jason was about two
megabytes sorry the when you store it
with as the binary Jason that's but more
than a megabyte and then when you
of the keys and have your own fields
it's about 600 K and that's what we have
right now so one project that tried to
solve this problem is a project called
captain proto we almost use captain
proto but when when we started working
into looking into crew passing feeds
like two or three years ago that had
just come out and I think it came out on
April 1st and it looks a little bit
silly but is actually a really good
library I'm not quite sure why they were
able to make that serial joke it's not
conflicts anyway so what captain proto
does it provides another way of creating
binary files so it's made by the people
who made protocol buffers if anybody has
ever heard of that
so it's like the next generation and the
idea of this format is that the format
that's used for interchange that's
inside the files is the same as the
in-memory representation so basically
all you have to do is when you want to
load a captain profile is you take the
file you'll load that into memory and
tell some sort of library that relates
to captain port oh well this is now my
captain portal file and then can start
interpreting the data inside it without
copying it elsewhere without
deserializing it so the way it works is
sort of like using c s-- c structs
and so it uses structs data that's
packed inside memories sitting next to
each other and it uses pointers to to
create structure that is like a tree and
the pointers are not an absolute terms
to remember of addresses and memory no
of course they are relative to the size
of the file itself so if you know where
you are in the file you can have say
well this is some other data and it's at
this particular address relative to the
you know the file itself so one point is
that capital proto is like c structs so
in order to work with these c structs
they use something called schemas where
we define what these files look like so
for example i define the schema for the
stops and it actually kind of looks like
c ish in a way so the file is relatively
simple schemas you have some ID
the top that you always have to put
there I think it's to make sure that the
the files have the format that you
expect then you could define you know
structures and here I define destruct
that's a stop and then you basically
have to give it a name and the type so
there's a text type that's a name and
then there's two floating point values
that are the latitude and the longitude
and there are all our values again and
you also have to give it and an index
you know you have to number the fields
through because you can actually later
add new values in the end and they will
still be sort of compatible like all the
versions of the library can still will
still be able to read these things as
long as the order of the far order of
the fields that were there before stay
the same so you can always add things in
the end it's kind of convenient so you
might have a you know struck referring
to the stop and then list off the stop
and when you have a schema like this you
in all sort of languages with captain
proto there's a tool called cap mmm
where you can generate like a C++
library that allows you to read this
particular these particular files in
Python we can use these schemers
directly it sort of looks like this so
you import captain PE that I with the
Python module and then you imports the
stops captain P which is basically this
schema file here like the captain P
module it has some sort of import hook
that overrides imports and it looks for
this underscore captain P just to gloat
the schema and then basically all of a
sudden this now becomes like a module so
if you want to pack a particular stop
you just say you know stops captain P
that's the module whether you know that
that is associated with the schema
create a new stop with you know say a
new message and then you assign all of
these values to it you can even also
just take the stop and just assign more
values to it so then when you want to
pack all of them you basically do the
same thing for all of the stops you just
say a new message and you assign the
values that are all you know the list of
stops that you create and the way you
actually then turn it into an actual
binary files
- just take the resulting object you
resulting poro objects and you just
write it into a file using the right
method that's pretty simple so the way
the data looks like I don't know it's
kind of hard to interpret at this point
it's really just a bunch of binary
gobbledygook but one thing to note is
that I put the whole data file there and
I put the beginning at the end and
actually the strings they end up in the
end of the file because what it does it
creates structs and then when it has to
refer to a string because the string is
not a fixed length it stores a pointer
and then the pointer store refers to the
strings that are then stored somewhere
in the end of the data so basically in
the beginning you have a list of structs
with pointers to strings towards the end
of the file one thing to notice that is
a lot of 0 bytes floating around so the
size is actually much larger than than
the message packed Master pack was what
600 K and now we have back to almost a
megabytes but given that these values
are all 0 you can always gzip it so if
you send it over the network you can
compress it in somewhere and probably
will end up the same smaller value so
the encoding of CAP record was actually
pretty smart it also uses a tree
structure but one thing I sort of didn't
like so much is that every struct has a
header that's like 64 bits and every
pointer is also 64 bits that seems like
a bit of a waste but the format is
incredibly powerful it you know it
includes features a guarding against
attacks so it doesn't just point to some
raw data in memory it uses it to read
the data but it's like the captain proto
object will refer to the data but when
you read a minute it will actually make
some checks to make sure that there's no
malicious data that it doesn't point to
outside off this the file that you've
loaded into memory so that you can't you
know snoop you can't create a malicious
file that slips onto memory that doesn't
belong to the file yes there's also
something dead smart and that if you
have a bunch of different values that
have different sizes like an in 64 next
to a buy it and then an in 16 it will
try to arrange them in a way that will
make the padding smart
yeah so another format that I really
can't get into because I don't really
have a lot of time is something called
flatbuffers
and it was developed by google to store
assets for games it's maybe something
that I would use nowadays it's a bit
more more bare-bones than captain Pronin
gives you a little bit more control but
also it gives you less powerful features
and it again it uses a struct light
representation and schemas to track the
data so when I looked at these options
and they didn't really exist and
flatbuffers what didn't exist when I was
writing this captain Porter was
incredibly new I didn't like this idea
of having schemas when I was using Jason
I could just dump a bunch of data into a
Jason and say well that's my that's
those are my stops why do I have to have
a separate file all those definitions
you know I'm I'm a friend of Python I
like my things to be typed but I don't
have to I don't want to declare things
and when I was thinking about how much
data there's some stops there there are
so many fields it seemed like crazy to
define all of these things manually and
also I wanted to have more control over
my bits like I wanted to really have bit
level control of my data so I was
thinking well why don't you just use
actual c structs why do I use some
library on top of that and it seems kind
of silly nowadays but you know this
actually is possible and you can
actually use bits and to decide what
every single byte of your file is and
you can use the structure model in
Python so the circ model is actually a
module that allows you to interchange
data between Python and C and I think
it's more used for like libraries
talking to each other or maybe to parse
an odd message coming from the web I
don't think it's really meant to be used
for for like large file formats but you
could use for it so you could have
something where you know like your
empordà struct and then with struct is
the pack method you should just give it
a type and a value right so you know
it's an integer you stole some number
and then you can store a byte and you
can store a character and then if you
they will read returned strings so you
can add them together and then you have
that one string so it's like it should
be seven bytes right so one two three
four five six bytes because this is a
byte so one character one bite and run
four bit integer so well I have exact
control over all of my bytes hey that's
what I want right
it seems kind of inconvenient the way I
have to define them so I thought myself
well I just want to write a little
helpful library my little helper library
turned out to be kind of large and I
just called it named struct because all
I wanted his names in the side destruct
so I just developed this on top of
structs and it allows me to have schemas
files that are nevertheless typed those
were the types I just specified just
like in the struct module when creating
the data so then when I create a stop
all they do is I go to the name struck
module and I say well give me a struct
and I give destructor name so by if I
give the start a name it suddenly has
sort of something typed that I can refer
to that name becomes its type and then I
can just basically add things to it so
the library is not very Python looking
I'm kind of sorry and I'm kind of still
stuck in the java world with my naming
convention don't have eight me so I'm
also using chaining this is also very
not pythonic but you can you don't have
to use chaining you can also just create
the struct object and then add a value
to it so every time I say add string
which that's the type that's the string
I give it a name which is called name in
this case I give it a value which is
basically the name of the value of the
stop and then here well what's this
reference but with so that's my idea of
having complete control over my bits and
the way I have complete well the thing
is that even even you have a string it
might have a variable length so cause it
cut so it can't be stored inside this
truck it has to be stored somewhere else
so actually what this creates is a
pointer to where the string actually
resides and since I have a very tree
like structure the string is going to be
stored just after the struct inside the
memory so since the struct is really
small I know that the offset the offset
from this struct to the data only needs
to be one byte big because the
destructor small I don't need values
bigger than 256 so that's what I did I
just created a reference bit width of
eight so now all of a sudden I have an 8
bit pointer well you can't do that and
captain proto all of the pointers are 64
bits in my thing then I saw the integer
in the latitude and the longitude in the
code in a service pattern ID and I saw
them as either signed or unsigned
integers
note that the latitude and longitude I
saw them as integers because I don't
have floats I figured in a series ation
format I don't really want to store
store raw floats because I'm not sure
exactly whether everybody's going to use
the same format if it's integers
everybody is using little-endian
integers nowadays so I can just dump
that in there and then I can read that
so I just converted them into and it's
kind of cheating as well because I'm
turning a double which is 8 bytes into
an integer which is 4 bytes but you know
it's compression right there so now I
have this little struck create it and
then when I create for every stop I can
just create an array of these things and
create another struct that is all of the
stuff so it's similar to Captain proto
but I don't have a separate schema the
schema is implied by the code because I
put values and I put types at the same
time so one little thing that I can do
with this now is I can print out one
side you know this pack stopped so the
pack stops function gives me one of
these name structure objects so if I
give the data out there it tells me
basically what values and what types
does it have
so the pretty function gives me an idea
to look at these things so I see right
at the top there's a list of stops and
the first stop at the first thing it has
a ref it has a reference sorry it's a
list of references that does all the
stop then every single stop is a struct
here that starts there I sorry I didn't
do the empty indentation properly this
is one stop and you see that the first
thing it is there's a reference 8 like
an 8 bit pointer to the string which
will be stored just below the struct and
then there is a bunch of padding bytes
and the padding or days.the this station
bullion flag and then there's a bunch of
padding bytes because everything needs
to be aligned properly because you're
actually reading it at c structs you
don't want to have misaligned data so
this get added in as necessary so I can
look at the pretty the pretty output to
see what it is but and also I can
generate a C header from that so because
this that the the file object is the
schema that's where generate my code
from so from from that data object i
generate my header file generation and
my header file
and that is actually used on on the on
the device inside the app it's a C++
code to read the data coming in and in
order to be able to do this you use this
attribute pack thing but it actually
works it might be like violating some
aliasing rules but you know I've done a
bunch of testing and it all sort of
works out and then of course you can
also just generate the binary blob so
that's what I do with pack and then I
have my binary blob blob file and now
the file is about 600 K which is smaller
than the kappa pro that was 900 further
I developed this thing further because
it just seems so wasteful to have all of
these you know I have an in 32 when most
of the time the values may be much
smaller
so I created a bunch of things that that
uses pitch fields and bit field arrays
and all of like little little things to
make it smaller to where I can't get
into it but I thought there was a whole
bunch of cleverness there and then also
at some point I decided that well those
strings are annoying if we won't have
compressed file you might as well
actually compress it using gzip because
Jesus works well with text so I
separated all all the names and I
separated all than the miracle data and
store them in separate things so then
the compressed strings about honey
kilobyte there's also a something in
there that makes it very fast to search
for names and then in the end I ended up
with 200 kilobytes and I could do this
because I have complete control of all
my bits so then in the final in the end
I have about 200 kilobytes using all of
my magic and hacking and the JSON was to
Anna Nagar byte message pack was 600 K
and captain Porter was 900 K presumably
if you actually use a very strong
compression those differences will get a
bit smaller so the idea that we used in
the end is that we have this binary file
where the memory and the in file
structure is the same that worked really
well that works also in captain Porter
and flatbuffers our representation is
much more compact than them and the
schema is separate it's not separate
it's in the code and then you can
generate it directly from objects this
turned out to be a little bit of a
liability
because once you file gets really really
large you need to have a feed
exhibits all of the possible fields that
you have because we're gonna have when
you generate the header file of it it
has to have everything in there so what
ended up happening is that we created a
special fake feed that we used as part
of our integration testing that exhibits
everything and that means that in order
to have a schema we have this fake feed
we have our compression then we generate
the header file the parsing library from
that once we've generated the feed so in
the end it's a bit of a pain I think
that actually schemas is the way to go I
mean it kind of hurts me to say also as
a Python person to having sever
declarations seems annoying and it's
maybe more time consuming but at the end
it's much more easy to maintain so my
story in the end is well I figured out a
bunch of bits and it's fun but maybe
it's better to stick with something that
somebody's written like captain Ford or
a flatbuffers and be happy that you have
schemas oh our binary format thing was
very much a success I mean we have to
schedule on the virus I think we're the
only transit app that actually has
offline schedules just like that and we
could do like offline routing if you
wanted to you could do all sorts of
things yes so I think that's basically
it what I have to say today so thank you
very much Thank You Anton we have three
minutes three and a half minutes for
questions please you talked a lot about
the data of the schedules how do you
bring the map to your to your app how do
I work what
the map the road the map or is it Google
that's cool okay but Google once you
start looking at it it will cache data
as well so if you go to a city and it
loads the feed and it starts downloading
the map then you get the map but it's
true I wasn't logged on and then I get a
gray map because it doesn't happen now
but I have to schedule great if I
understood correctly the names checked
data format is a record oriented format
but a record oriented one recall after
the other yes
have you tried to experiment with
columnar indeed
realization where for a specific
attribute you have all the values but
the one after the other like parquet for
instance and to benefit from better
compression in that case so what I ended
up doing in the end is creating are
using bit fields when I know that I have
data where I know that I'm not using 32
bits I started using bit fields so in
bit fields you don't align data to byte
burning byte boundaries anymore
you have bit value so you might have
five engine and record with five values
and one has 13 bits and one is 16 bits
and one is 18 bits but you don't know
how many bits you will have a priori you
can't define this statically you know
because it depends on the data so what
we used we created something where
there's a small header file that defines
how many bits every field takes and how
many fields they are and then it's just
breakfast off these data's where the
records might take 27 bits that are like
eight bits seven bits and nine bits or
something like that and that works
really well and it's completely random
access and whether you store it like as
a list of records or just all of them
individually I don't think it really
makes a difference but we we did do this
and that's why what I mentioned when I
when I got down to about 200 kilobytes
that's basically what I used and I kind
of hoped that this sort of format might
makes it into captain Porter as well or
flatbuffers because it's it makes things
much smaller you don't have a bunch of
zeros everywhere one more last question
10 seconds long no longer
nobody Thank You Anton very much thank
you very much